for Regina mtonga the Internet is a
little bit of freedom she says it makes
people more self-reliant which is
especially important for women in Zambia
Regina's 27 and a self-employed web
designer I went to college and I started
I studied the degree in computer science
which had zero to no experience in web
sites it's only later on two years that
I taught myself how to make websites
through YouTube videos and also my
husband taught me a few things and I did
the rest now Regina is passing on her
know how in 2012 she founded the Aussie
Connor network with two friends to teach
women IT and computer technology they
faced daunting obstacles it's very
difficult for women to first of all
enter into IT and remain in IT because
we we get a little hate pork and hate
behavior from people because the first
thing people would tell you is you can't
do that because you're a woman Regina
hasn't had it easy in 2013 her father
and mother died within a short time of
each other she was left to care for
herself and her younger sister I feel
like God had taken my mom awaits and I
honestly felt like he was punishing me
for something that ahead I could have in
his hand
anything that could possibly go bad was
going bad in in my life january2014 I
must honestly say that my life did
change it was a change for the better a
year later her work finally gained
recognition and from very high up to
someone called Fabian called and she
said Regina I just wanted to be the
first one to tell you and we have been
selected to be one of the 60 Queens
young leaders the first 60 Queens and
leaders of 2015 and a guy came ask you
why I was making so much noise and I
told them I'm going to meet the Queen
the Queen of England I finally meet the
Queen she's been very busy ever since
seem like some members Regina has become
a role model for many young women in
Zambia they come to her classes to learn
how to run their own businesses I think
something of notice about them is that
they have felt so empowered that they
feel they no longer have to be working a
nine-to-five job for someone else but
they tend to want to work for themselves
and it has been very successful for them
we have some very good examples of girls
who are their own bosses not making more
money than I am Regina and her network
have achieved something crucial to show
Zambian women that they can have control
over their own lives